good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact instead
of help you on your journey today's
message is don't have any regrets over
to you brené Brown what I have found in
my life and what I found in my research
which fueled what I did in my life is
that the people who have the most
courage who are willing to show them be
the most vulnerable are the ones who are
very clear about who the critics are the
ones who reserved seats for them and say
I hear you I get it I know where the
messaging is coming from I'm not I'm not
an I'm not buying it anymore so to get
very clear the last thing which I think
is the hardest is this one of these
seats needs to be reserved for you one
of these seats needs to be reserved for
me I need when we look up and we're
putting an idea our piece of art our
design forward who do you think the
biggest critic in the arena normally is
yourself and so definitely me like I
have never watched either of those TED
Talks
because it's not in service of the work
for me and I try to do things are only
in service of my work because what would
what would it serve for me to watch it I
would sit there and go oh my god suck in
your stomach oh my god that's not what
you were gonna say you know we're so
self-critical and one of the things that
I think happens and I think this happens
a lot it happens in different
professions but I think I see it a lot
with creatives is there is an ideal of
what you're supposed to be and what a
lot of us end up doing is we orphan the
part
of ourselves that don't fit what that
ideal is supposed to be and what it
leaves when we orphan all those parts of
us is it just leaves the critic and so
reserved in this seat is this where we
came from how we started our families
that's me the oldest of course the lost
years the years where I was so lost and
confused and hurt and disillusioned that
I thought the only path to freedom was a
flock of seagulls haircut
the higher the hair the closer to God we
say in Texas
the people who love us the moments that
make us who we are and in that cheer
should be this person the person who
believes in what we're doing and why
we're doing it and the person who says
yeah it's so scary to show up
it feels dangerous to be seen it's
terrifying but it is not as scary
dangerous or terrifying as getting to
the end of our lives and thinking what
if I would have shown up what would have
been different the fear of regret is one
of the most powerful forces that I know
to help you take action immediately and
push through the fear of doing whatever
big thing it is that you have to do
because whenever you have a big idea
whenever you want to try something new
whenever you want to push the boundaries
and go off and explore it's scary all
the most meaningful things that you will
do in your life will come on the other
side of fear you will have to push
through that fear tool to do those
amazing things if you're constantly
bumping up against that wall of fear and
you always back down you're gonna always
play in this really small circle were
the most successful people the ones who
are rule breakers the one who are doing
the most visionary amazing things in the
world entrepreneurs like me and you
you've got to be able to push through
that fear the fear is real it's not the
fear doesn't exist the figure is
absolutely real but pushing through the
fear allows you to get to the other side
and some does you look back and say you
know what that wasn't that scary
sometimes you look back and say that was
actually really crazy scary but I got
through it and now I'm stronger and now
I can do more my muscles have built I'm
capable of helping even more than what I
was able to do before
and so the power of regret for me helps
me overcome that immediate fear where if
I want to do something and I'm afraid I
try to fast forward to the end of my
life is a Jeff Bezos analogy you know
however old that is if we're living the
300 years old by the time we get there
I'm 300 looking back in my life
I don't want a lifetime of having
wondered what if what if I had just done
that what if I had just said yes to it
what if I just wasn't as afraid and push
through and
being more cowardly and saying no and
try to imagine you know 300 years of
that that fear of forever regret then
becomes larger than the immediate fear
of whatever I have to do next and by
doing that by making that fear bigger it
forces me to action
it's like if you stubbed your toe and
it's really hurting but then somebody
punches you in the arm you don't feel
your toe anymore because the arm hurts
more so that's what you're paying
attention to so by focusing on the
bigger future fear of regret it makes
the other fear of doing that small
action not as big and so I have to go
out and do that action does that make
sense and so I got my biggest taste of
regret when I was 18 years old I was in
Paris this girl came up to me I wanted
to ask her out she was asking for
directions and and I was too afraid to
and long story short she left and I went
on my way and I felt like why didn't I
do that like you know why didn't I just
ask her out why is it so difficult to
get that those few words out there and I
regretted it and so I took a picture I
tried to catch her in the picture but
but you know she wasn't in it
she walked behind a market and I when I
got home I put that picture up on my
wall as a daily reminder that I'm not
gonna live with regret I'm knockin with
her bread I would rather deal with
failure I could deal with the failure I
can deal with the rejection I can deal
with the the know what I can't deal with
is not knowing I have to know
knowing is more powerful than not
knowing and potentially getting rejected
when I got the opportunity to join that
startup company in my first real
business I had opportunities to go work
at the companies that I thought I wanted
to work at and make 80 to 100 case
starting salary and flyer on the world
it's like the dream job I thought I
wanted for a good chunk of my life and
here was this chance to look at this
startup company where I'm gonna make 300
bucks a month and it was that picture on
the wall that daily reminder of the next
time I get hit with this opportunity
that I might regret not doing right then
I know I have to go out and do it and by
looking at that picture every day when I
walked home it started seeping into my
subconscious right like I'm not gonna
live with regret the next time
opportunity comes I'm gonna jump on it
and so I did the unsafe thing the scary
thing that push you through the fear
thing and said you know what I can I can
always get a job next year it may not be
the same job I mean it'd be as good a
job and I do it the company that I
thought I wanted I can deal with that
not working but I can't deal with not
knowing about this start that startup
takes off and those really well I'm
gonna be pissed that I wasn't a part of
it that I said no to it and so that
Paris experience helped me say yes to
this company and I'm built and sold my
first business and I haven't gone back
to working in a job since and every time
that I felt that feeling of I might
regret this like I might regret not
knowing I have to go out and do it even
if it's a total failure and so I've had
a couple of those come up even recently
when I started working with the agency
that I was at I wasn't sure if I wanted
to do it
I didn't know if it was a fit but I felt
like I needed to know and so I went and
did it when I thought about going to a
Tony Robbins conference and I brought
five people on my team to go down and
pay for them to go there I thought this
might be a big waste of money I might
have just dropped 10k for big waste of
money but I needed to know then I get
the return maybe was it worth it maybe
it wasn't zero was the value 10k maybe
was it 15k maybe was a 5k maybe but I
don't care so much about that money
because I wanted to know what I don't
want is about twenty years of wondering
what if I just took my team to the Tony
Robbins event same thing when there was
that event climber con for youtubers I
hate going to networking events I hate
going to conferences unless I'm speaking
I was not speaking at this event do you
want to be they wanted me to come as a
as a guest just an invitee and
collaborate with other people like I
hate networking events I don't go into
these things I haven't been the one in
years I wrote these things off but this
one looks a little bit different it's
only for youtubers is only for people
the hundred thousand subscribers plus I
might regret it if I don't go and so I
booked my ticket and it took me three
days three or four days out of my
schedule to go and do it did I get the
return on the investment again I don't
know I met Charlie from Chris on command
I met Tim Schmoyer Roberto Blake a bunch
of people that I'd never met in
person but I knew online and we
connected and we're on skype calls but I
got to meet them in person was that
worth the trip
maybe but what's much more worth it this
is the thing like it's not being
attached to results it's just knowing
being attached to knowing going out and
doing it so that I know and if it
doesn't work out great I've learned if
it works out fantastic and I can go out
and do it again and I would just so
strongly encourage you that if you ever
feel that fear of doing something and
that in the future you might regret it
like you know if you don't do this
you're gonna regret it for the rest of
your life you have to do it it's the
world shaking you to say wake up you got
to go do this thing and make that future
fear bring it back to today all of those
years decades or centuries to end of
today I make that fear bigger than the
immediate fear of whatever it is that
you're afraid to do this work for me
it's one of the most important lessons
ever learned in my life and I hope it
works for you so the question today
today is I'm curious what is one thing
that you might regret not doing but you
haven't taken action on yet you'll
regret it if you don't at least find out
what is that thing leave in the comments
below I'm really curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shot of -
Stephanie Bisbee Stephanie thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one-word really really really means
a lot to me and I hope you're enjoying
the reading thank you guys again for
watching I hope you have an amazing day
I believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of an espresso
I spray so give me go
when I decided to do this I I first
talked to my my wife who is sitting here
in the audience and she had married a
you know relatively stable goofy but
still relatively stable a person working
at a Wall Street firm I worked at a
quantitative hedge fund and this was a
hard decision and I was looking for the
right framework in which to make that
kind of important decision and and and
and and the right framework I found is a
regret minimization framework and that's
just a nerdy way of saying that you want
to project yourself to age 80 and then
think back over your life and and if
you're if you're if you're 81 or the
thew want to minimize the number of
regrets you have throughout that period
of time I think this is something a lot
of people do maybe subconsciously they
probably very few people probably name
it regret minimization framework because
most people are healthier than that but
but it was a very clear way for me to
think about making that kind of life
decision and then and in the way it
helped was I thought okay if I go do
this thing and participate in this thing
called the Internet that I genuinely
believe is gonna be a big deal and if I
fail am I gonna regret having tried and
failed and I knew the answer that was no
but I also knew that if I didn't try
that I would always regret that I would
always wonder and it would haunt me and
until that you know mythical day which I
actually hope will come I started
traveling I had been to a bunch of
countries really liked it I lived in
West Africa for four years and started
kind of trying to figure out okay how
many countries have I been to how many
countries in the world are there once I
had this information it was very
difficult to do anything else right
because once I had this information I
was like oh I've been to like 50
countries there's 193 countries it was
192 I would like to visit a hundred
countries some time in my life I set
that goal first you know but you just
said you say I would like to because I
would like to do a lot of things but I
don't know I want to I feel drawn to it
I feel like this is a goal I'm gonna you
know
attached to myself and at the time it
wasn't public it was just like a private
thing this is before I was blogging you
know and then as I started getting
closer to that goal of a hundred
countries that's when I thought well
what's next because if you're only going
to half the countries then you're
missing a lot of challenges and you
could just go to easy places so that's
when I so I had this information of like
okay could I really do you know that was
like could I really go to every country
I don't know if I could or not like this
is like a huge thing it's gonna cost a
lot not just in terms of money but also
in terms of time and like sacrifice and
logistics things could go wrong you know
fear but really what it came down to
meat to for me was not the fear of
something going wrong along the way once
I actually started thinking about this
and was like maybe I could actually do
this in like seven to eight years if I
really worked at it what I was afraid of
was not doing it I was afraid of like
you know having this idea and then just
passing on it right you know and just
continuing to travel a little bit I'm
that guy who travels once in a while but
what's that you know like and then I
didn't want to get old right and be like
you know oh once it like ten years ago I
had this idea you know to do something
but I never did anything about it you
know that's what that's what drove me
the fear of being ordinary or if not the
fear of regret of not following up on a
dream that I that I had that I knew I
didn't know if I could succeed I thought
I might fail but I figured if I failed I
could deal with that you know but not if
I just didn't do it if this 71 year old
mr. button could go back to the younger
amita's and hold his hand and say don't
take this path go here instead at what
moment would that feel I'd never say
that because I think that whatever
happened I wouldn't want to change it I
feel that many of the mishaps or the
wrong decisions or the failures that I
had were great learning graphs for me I
think I'm a lot wiser now no one is the
ultimate person as far as wisdom is
concerned so I I feel that I wouldn't
want to change anything and just
continue the way I'm going
once it was one will this volume you
have the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be kind of like a little
beacon hey believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details